you probably remember back to when EA
and Bioware were first marketing Mass
Effect Andromeda and telling us all the
things we were in store for in the new
game there was one word that Bioware
devs kept using during that time that
made me start to worry they go
everything was going to be bigger
at one point Bioware sad that one of
them multiple explorable story worlds
would be the size of Dragon Age
Inquisition as a whole as someone who
poured 120 hours into Inquisition and
enjoyed it very much that should have
excited me but it just set off alarm
bells in my head and made me wonder what
exactly is in all this extra space it
turns out the answer that question is
not heaps if you want to get an idea of
what I mean you can subscribe to us on
YouTube and check out the Mass Effect
Andromeda content we have there but for
now let me tell you where I'm going with
all this I can't help but feel like Mass
Effect Andromeda is unfinished the
sci-fi RPG elements are still there but
it feels like many of the things that
made the series special have been gutted
the engaging dialogue from colorful
exciting and sometimes tragic characters
is rare at best you can no longer kid
out your companions and they're leveling
options are severely limited which made
me feel even more apathetic toward them
and the things Bioware has expanded on
like crafting and large-scale world
exploration feel tedious it's such a big
step back not just for Mass Effect about
for Bioware and while playing Andromeda
I can't help but wonder how this
happened
personally I blame that word bigger now
I understand that when a lot of you guys
hear bigger you hear more bang for your
buck and I get that if you're paying for
a full pressed game 60 hours of gameplay
sounds better than 20 but personally
I'll always take quality over quantity
if a game is already great at 10 hours I
wouldn't want a developer to potentially
make it mediocre by drawing it out to 20
for the sake of more playtime for
example if games like Journey Firewatch
or portal would Rona unnecessarily it
may not have had the same impact
Andromeda includes huge sections of
chasing objective markers and talking to
uninteresting NPCs it means there's a
lot of extra hours of game in there sure
but it feels like unsatisfying padding
that doesn't contribute much to the
tenants of
make mass effect games so good meeting
fascinating people and feeling like a
hero I don't know about you but I don't
feel particularly heroic trying to make
my way to get another Waypoint to
deliver random assorted supplies while
switching the Nomad between regular mode
and lumbering slight hill climbing mode
for 10 minutes apiece of course these
sorts of missions are optional but in
Andromeda you can never tell if a
missions going to be worthwhile until
you're actually doing it sometimes side
quests that seem trivial at first end up
revealing really cool content but even
more often side missions with
interesting story justifications still
devolve into boring fetch quest gameplay
once you get started I felt the same way
about nerman sky when that nade release
I mean that whole shtick was you'd have
18 quintillion planets to explore which
is great but it led me to thinking all
right what's on them size and scope mean
nothing if you don't have a compelling
reason for said size big for the sake of
big is well exactly the problem with
Andromeda that's not to say big can't be
done well games like The Witcher 3 and
the Skyrim are great examples of worlds
that feel full and vibrant while being
pretty damn massive I loved seeing the
terrain change under my feet while
traversing Tamriel and in both games you
often stumble upon intriguing characters
and side quests that make it well worth
exploring the sprawling game world
the problem with bigger isn't just empty
spaces in between points of interest
either it's also the features that get
sidelined during development in the
pursuit of making everything else more
expansive Mass Effect Andromeda
animation issues are a perfect example
if we take the word of ex Bioware
animator Jonathan Cooper
it sounds like Bioware had likely
intended to code every facial animation
individually but with 1200 plus speaking
characters this year size of that task
meant it didn't happen if Cooper's right
the bulk of the work was left up to
automated algorithms and the end result
is well this fortunately a little better
now that there's been a patch but you
can still see the effects back in
November of last year ea said it would
happily delay Mass Effect Andromeda for
a second
if it felt the game needed more time to
be improved it was originally delayed
from 2016 until the first quarter of
this year and as you probably noticed it
did indeed come out after just one delay
so EA must have decided they were happy
enough with the final product to not
push the release date back again I don't
think any alma de is a bad game there
are some great character moments says
that sense of wonder when you're landing
on a new planet and I personally really
enjoyed establishing settlements
it just feels hollar some missions wrap
up with an unceremonious email in your
inbox rooms are mostly filled with
characters who don't speak and while you
can now ask the twelve hundred odd
speaking characters more questions than
you could in any previous Bioware game I
found myself unwilling to broach further
conversation because the NPC's weren't
interesting enough that I wanted to know
more about them I mean I lost anyway
because I'm a completionist but honestly
I don't really care about Joe schmo's
reasons for coming to Andromeda when I
know I'll never speak to him again I'm
sure I'll keep playing Andromeda in the
hopes that it improves and because of my
love for the original Mass Effect
trilogy
but it is hard not to think about what
the game could have been the combat
system improvements demonstrate that the
current Bioware team can deliver
something better for the mass effect
formula but I wish it had gone further
than just improved combat to be fair a
few of my friends have told me that Mass
Effect Andromeda totally kicks into gear
at the forty fifty hour mark so make it
that what you will
oh that's just my opinion though so let
me know where you land on Andromeda and
if there are any games that you think do
big really well or not so well I'll
catch you again next time